you guys hear me
I don't do I need this to speak can you
hear me okay if I'm just like this or
should you want me to speak into them
okay we'll okay guys so
um yeah I've I've learned so much
already this morning uh from this
morning this afternoon's first talk so
um I'm gonna talk about some work that
I've been doing with bottlenose dolphins
and um I've been really trying to also
like you decode the communication
signals of other species and as you as
many of you know there's been a history
of people working trying to find our
ways of giving other species of code
that we can share and Brian you were
speaking to some of this helped me come
halfway to meet them and um in decoding
my colleagues and I have tried to use
two approaches I think they're two
really and probably many more paths that
we can take but um in the work we've
done and this is this I started my lab
back in
1979. yeah no I was a student in 1970. I
opened my lab in 1983 after I got my PhD
and I thought wow if we want to try to
communicate or figure out how other
animals are communicating we can use
um observational techniques listening
recording their signals
um using computers to analyze their data
the data we're getting but um but there
may be another way where we can use an
interactive system with them where we
try to again meet them halfway and uh
that's a lot of the work I've been
trying to do and we're continuing to do
it today so first let me introduce you
to my collaborator and I honestly mean I
consider these as my research
collaborators because in watching them
they kind of show you what to do next
you know I've I always tell the students
in my lab don't be so fast to make a
hypothesis to try to figure out what to
test just watch them listen to them find
your own way of seeing and hearing them
and you know patterns emerge that others
may not have seen and we may be wrong
most of the time because most of the
time what we do is failing but sometimes
we get lucky and um but it's fun to fail
in a lot of ways and then you you try
other things so today I want to just
talk to you a little bit about some of
the work we done and trying to decode
dolphin communication a lot of what
we've done is looking at vocal
development from birth on and trying to
understand how Dolphins use their own
repertoires and I've studied cognition
as well not that communication isn't
cognition it's all sort of the same
thing so we did some studies I'm not
going to talk about this but in terms of
the cognitive work this is a dolphin
playfully watching herself spin in a
mirror and some of the work we've done
looking at cognition is giving Dolphins
ways of showing us what I call their
best stuff so if you give a dolphin or
an elephant we've done both studies with
dolphins and elephants mirrors what we
found was that they like us like great
apes and a handful of other species
recognize themselves in a mirror they
have this level of awareness of self
which is pretty sophisticated that many
other animals don't
um and in general I've been trying to
find ways that approaches that give us
glimpses of aspects of the dolphin mind
their communication and their cognition
and I try to give them things that I
think will be enriching for them because
mostly uh the Dolphins I've worked with
I've worked with in uh that are in
Aquaria because I feel that if I'm going
to give them artificial signals and
you'll hear about some of the work we've
done I didn't want to put the artificial
signals into the wild because I wasn't
sure ethically if I wanted to do that I
thought well the Dolphins we have in
Aquaria probably need enriched
environments why don't we try to give
them choice and control and try to find
out more of their cognitive abilities so
we've used mirrors we've used underwater
keyboards we're now we've now created a
dolphin touch screen which hopefully
I'll have some time to tell you about to
see what happens if we give them a means
of interaction so I'll sort of try to
take you through a trip about a little
bit of this research today so uh France
already told you a good deal about
dolphins I'll go through this really
quickly uh he covered a lot in his
beautiful talk this morning Dolphins
like us have big complex brains their
brains are larger than ours ours ours
are about 1300 grams there's weigh in at
about 1700 grams again these are
bottlenose dolphins and uh they have uh
their brain is second largest in terms
of uh what we call the EQ
encephalization quotient the their brain
size to body size or brain mass to
bodyginess as ours these are again the
second largest in terms of EQ to us
humans here's this big beautiful brain I
don't study the neuro biology of these
brains but other colleagues do but I'm
really interested in what they're doing
with these brains so we're going to
bypass that and get into what what's
going on here a little bit from what we
can see and again honestly we're in the
infancy of these studies still
um Dolphins as we heard from France
earlier live in complex Societies in the
Seas some of our work is in the wild let
me see I can bring this up a little bit
more
we've worked in uh in Bimini and Belize
but watching them we will slip into the
water and stay at a distance and record
what they're doing and then uh try to
analyze them and we haven't actually
even started working with folks doing Ai
and I'm really excited about some new
connections we're making here today
dolphins are non-handed yet they're
highly manipulative
um and we've seen I'm not going to show
you all the the videos I I cut this
because it would go too long but we've
watched dolphins in Aquaria create
beautiful bubble Rings blowing earrings
from their blowhole and monitoring them
and kicking them with their tails when
they're ill-formed and then producing
new ones if we have time I can show you
some of that a little bit but in the
wild they manipulate their environment
as well they're non-handed but they blow
uh they make not blow they blow uh
humpbacks and other animals will create
bubble Nets to capture prey and they
work collaborative collaboratively in
many any of their foraging activities
they can forge by themselves using
barrier feeding but they do more
collectively in child rearing in a
rather Offspring rearing uh in mating
behaviors and in foraging they're highly
Cooperative as well and we're looking at
some Cooperative Behavior right now
we're actually watching how Dolphins
coordinate their behavior when they're
asked to do a task do something that's
different that you've done before and do
it with your buddy so I don't have those
results in yet but that's a study we're
currently doing
Dolphins again live in complex Societies
in the Seas they sh they have a fission
fusion social structure they have long
lasting relationships they show empathic
Behavior caregiving Behavior they show
comparable cognitive abilities with
great apes and they're vocal Learners
and that's what I'm going to be talking
about more today Dolphins show a really
strong proclivity for vocal learning and
vocal imitation and because of this I
thought maybe we could create a system
that would give them novel signals that
were unlike the signals they were
producing but within the time and
frequency domain of things they could
produce to meet them halfway yeah Brian
I'm with you on this one
so um I'm going to talk about some of
that work using what we observe from
them again partnering with them they're
giving me the ideas of what to do I
didn't get this by myself
and again one of the things that I felt
so that's so compelling and we've heard
this from a lot of the speakers today is
if we're trying to decode what's the
nature of their lexicon what's the
smallest unit of sound that they're
making we don't know how would we
possibly find out we need some Cipher to
be able to figure out what they're doing
how do you get a cipher how do we get
some kind of insight into discovering
what they're about the other questions
are what about their syntax what kind of
temporal organization do we see of these
signals even if we don't know the
smallest unit how are they temporally
organized and of course to be able to
understand that we need to know how to
do signal how to attribute certain
signals to certain individuals because
if we're just hearing a mishmash of
signals how do we know they're even
related to each other when we look at
these groups so sound localization is a
key aspect in that and we heard some
ways of doing that today with d tags in
a variety of other signals and then
finally what about the meaning or
semantics of these signals so
interestingly
um and my background was in bioacoustics
and communication Theory and when when
you think about semantics one of the
basic tenets of communication theory is
that meaning is not in the signal I mean
we tend to think meaning what's the
meaning of a word the meaning is in us
we generate meanings hopefully they're
shared enough across individuals but
absolute meaning is not in the message
itself it's in how it's interpreted by
receivers and senders
there's some some general kind of
meaning or we wouldn't be able to
communicate with each other but meaning
is generally in in in in us so instead
of talking worrying about semantics I
think for us who for us folks who want
to study animal signals if we think
about pragmatics or function how it's
used and I'll just one of my favorite
one of my favorite stories was told by
Gregory Bateson and he talked about that
he and his I think his wife at the time
was Margaret Mead they had taken their
they had taken their their son on a trip
to Mexico and their son didn't know
Spanish and
um they were unpacking their bags in
their hotel room and they suddenly heard
their son out playing in the street with
a few of his kids they were playing a
game of football and they heard their
son yelling akiyaki and he would get the
ball
he didn't know the language and when he
came upstairs they said how did you know
what that meant and he said I don't know
what it meant I just watched what
happened when people yelled at kiyake
and I got the ball so I think that's the
level if we're really good at observing
um and watching how these signals are
correlated with behavior it may give us
a key
hopefully so one of the first things I
did when I started trying to study
dolphins is I started making a
dictionary of their sounds and each one
of this these is a little sound
spectrogram again uh frequency on this
axis across time and um Brenda McGowan
who is probably listening today uh with
her with her students um we started
trying to look at uh what the Dolphins
were doing from birth on and we were
able to learn when they started
echolocating how that developed we did
some studies of vocal ontogeny from
birth on and then also we looked at the
vocal repertoires but it's really hard
to look at these signals when again we
have no Cipher how do we know what is
this is this one element here and then
is this another element are they
combinatorial or is this one uh one
signal how do we know how it's organized
and we're still kind of miffed at this
so we studied vocal learning in young
Dolphins to try to watch a simple system
develop over time and I think we did get
some insights
um again I'm not going to have enough
time to talk too much about that right
now because I want to focus on other
work but we did show that Dolphins like
birds which were our main model for
vocal learning showed babbling they over
produced sounds and
um and we had looked at the adult vocal
repertoires in this pool we only had
three Dolphins two females and a male
and they gave birth to two young
dolphins and that's the group we watched
so we looked at their repertoires and we
looked at how a simple system develops
over the first year and again we saw
evidence for babbling over production
and attrition of those sounds much like
we see in young children
and then
uh the work that we did uh the work has
continued over the years uh more
currently we've been using and I've been
doing work with my colleague Marcella
magnasco who's a biophysicist at the
Rockefeller University we've been
working in the field
um using unmanned aerial systems drones
to watch Dolphins we're recording from a
boat that's Downstream and I'm wondering
if I can get the sound a little bit
louder I'm sorry I'm not borrowing
David's computer
um and here we get these beautiful uh
shots where we're not disturbing them
and we can start seeing hopefully
patterns that are associated with uh
acoustic patterns that are associated
associated with some of their behaviors
this is uh Dolphins at an area where
they're foraging so I think this is
really
um very has a huge potential for us to
see patterns again of interaction I'm
just sort of the beginning of
appropriate of some of the approaches
we've taken but what I'm going to talk
about today
primarily is the study that I did a lot
we did a long long time ago in an
aquarium far far away this actually not
so far far away because we're in
California this aquarium was really
close I gave this talk to David's class
similar talk when I was in New York I'm
at Hunter College but I we actually did
this right up the road here at Marine
World Africa USA and um the idea was
that if what if we give Dolphins a
non-handed species an underwater
keyboard now I told you they were
manipulative and they can manipulate
things with their Rostrum and I was
really inspired by studies that people
had been doing of using sign language
with chimps uh or keyboards with chims I
mean pepperberg is a close friend of
mine as well and I actually work on her
with her group
um I'm her vice president of the Alex
foundation and I was really intrigued by
the idea of giving them some kind of
shared code so with the help of Euler
Packard and funding from Ampex and Yola
Packard and a variety of other places we
built this underwater keyboard system
this is where I started feeling really
old we did this in 1983 84. wow we
barely could do it we developed this
underwater keyboard that was interfaced
with fiber optic cables it was run on
light so it would be care it would be
safe into an apple to computer you
believe in apple II computer oh my God
and um here's the way it worked the
question first of all was what would
happen if we gave these really big
brains thinking about them almost like
ex non-terrest they're non-terrestrials
they're totally aquatic I didn't want to
train dolphins I wanted to work with a
big brain and give them choice and
control let's assume they're really
intelligent what happens if we give them
a system that they can control and we're
subject to doing what they want us to do
so
um many many years prior to this uh some
other scientists Kellogg's at Kellogg
and rice had done studies showing that
Dolphins could visually discriminate
white forms against the black background
so we based this on some old work I did
some other studies from some of my
doctoral work to make sure they could
discriminate this in air or when it was
two-dimensional but for ease of the
Dolphins we made them three-dimensional
so when this was submerged underwater
they could use echolocation or vision
and each of these is is real is uh
removable so the symbols appeared on the
keyboard in pseudo-random ways so if the
Dolphins were going to use a particular
symbol
and here's just a little diagram if they
hit a triangle they would hear
a particular whistle it sounds like that
it was a computer-generated call and
they would get a ball these we picked
things that they showed a preference for
um whoops let me back up for a minute if
they hit an H shape they would get a
tickle or a rub from us uh and and hear
a different sound so each of these
symbols was associated with a different
sound again within the their own time
frequency domain but different than
their existing signals and we put sort
of flat Parts on this so we could pick
them apart and again I did this work
with Brenda McGowan who came to the lab
after the first year of this work and
did the analysis with me on this
um so the question is if we gave them
control over this and they had control
over contingencies what would happen
again remember they show a strong
proclivity for vocal imitation
so the way this works whoops once again
is we um we had two births at Marine
World we studied their vocal development
and then when they were about 11 months
old we put the uh we put we gave them
and their moms a keyboard so it was in a
social context because learning is a
social is a social uh Behavior it we
wanted it to be in a social context
so what the Dolphins could do this is
when they were a bit older because this
ran for two years
um and we were down two years because we
had to move Marine World Africa USA
where we did this study that was in
Redwood City we were down for two years
we picked it up when we moved to
Northern California in Vallejo uh North
of San Francisco and Vallejo so here is
Delphi one of the two uh young males
that was born in the facility if he hits
a key he hears a sound
and we give him the corresponding object
so I would be my either my student or I
would be wearing a headset standing
behind the keyboard there was no right
and wrong answer and we would have to
oblige by giving them what they had
asked for and again the keys were
pseudo-randomized I have to tell you one
funny quick story here I'm just going to
watch the time
we had initially given them a key for
fish
ball and rub three different categories
and um one of the Dolphins started using
it first pan these were two young
dolphins and their moms
the mothers didn't use the keyboard it
was the youngsters that did which was
interesting in it in itself the mothers
took this as a giant babysitting device
I like to joke about this because they
were very Vigilant until we put the
keyboard in always one of them was
always with the two off the two calves
so pardon me
after the keyboard when the keyboard
wasn't in they were Vigilant again but
when the keyboard went in they started
resting and the little guys could be by
themselves any of us who have had the
kids could are very would be
appreciative of this situation
so um the first we had first given them
three options it was either a fish King
which was a circle ball or rub and uh
the first dolphin who started pan
started using fish key
right away and he wasn't even eating
fish yet he was still they were they
nursed until they were about three or
four years old started eating the
mouthing the fish the other dolphin was
just watching and I just decided after a
couple of weeks I was going to remove
the food key which we did and the first
day we removed the food key they had
there were three symbols on a nine key
Matrix and the symbols would be moved
around the first day the fish key wasn't
there he's looking and he would always
come up and hit the fish key he went
down to the bottom of the pool and
picked up a piece of fish and held it
against the blank key
I I we didn't do anything because he
would have just continued to do that but
I think that's pretty telling of what
was intended there I mean these are
smart animals
um what we found was they started to
actively use the touch of the keyboard
and here's just an underwater piece from
PBS show nature that they did this is an
underwater view of them looking towards
the cameraman in the pool but this is
what it looks like from a dolphin's
point of view they hit the key uh they
get the corresponding object hear a
sound and then they can do anything with
it they are in charge of the show here
okay so and sometimes they'd want to
interact with us uh sometimes they'd
want to just play by themselves this was
Delphi and pan their mothers were with
them in the pool the whole time and
that's sort of the way it worked
yeah Brian it was interesting that you
you chose to make I would I would have
guessed that you would make the round
symbol for the ball and did you
purposefully not do that you know analog
yeah I didn't want it to be iconic
and there was nothing representational
about any of the sounds with the objects
either they were totally arbitrary again
remember we were in the infancy of all
this I barely knew what what we were
doing on this so what we found was that
after very few trials the Dolphins
imitated these signals so after 19
exposures to the ball they started
imitating I'll show you how they did it
after uh nine exposures to rub imitation
ring two exposures two years later when
we reintroduced it they imitated disc
and Float after the first time really
fast with great Fidelity so this is what
was so exciting so again these are
spectrograms the I don't have a point do
I have a point around here yeah so
uh let me see I can't no okay I'll just
kids so at the top that's the ball
signal in a they did the end of the ball
signal first that's a nice example of
the recency effect
okay next time this was pan same dolphin
ball signal he does the beginning
okay very sensitive to time and
frequency of these signals next time
matching harmonics structure it doesn't
look exactly he's lost some of the
Fidelity to the Contour but it sounds
just like it it's got the Timbre right
and the very next time puts it all
together in one that's the first
evidence we had for the process of vocal
learning in in these guys we know that I
mean it was astonishing to see it
yeah so you know for us those
happy birthday to you is the same as
happy birthday to you are they doing
absolute pinch or is it a relative oh
and this was critical for decoding again
what we did was we looked I said not all
my slides are here but I'm not a little
bit because I'm using I didn't know I
was giving this talk today so um let me
show you this so here we have I'm going
to answer that question a second I just
can't show it to you so here we have
computer version of ring the dolphin
before it's even halfway
produced pretty good imitation so not
only do they do the app they can match
the absolute frequency in time but then
they started to do compressions and
control and compressions and expansions
in both the time frequency domain the
thing that was preserved is Contour okay
they were it was that was the Salient
part and when you think about biological
systems like our own weak I can say fire
or fire and I can say it higher lower
shorter or longer so I think for us at
the time this was 1983 I had 1984 we
were doing this we were doing a lot of
um we were trying to figure out how to
analyze these signals and we know we we
need to normalize them if we're going to
analyze them now so that was a big key
in and then uh we also so I just don't
have this I can't show you the
compression and expansion but we have
that I just didn't have it on this one
we found that the Dolphins would start
to spontaneously imitate but they were
also producing these signals and what I
mean by that is we we defined imitation
as if if they did these facsimiles
within five seconds of the model sound
We call we Define production if it
wasn't following the model sound so they
could come up to the keyboard and and
Purdue use that sound ball and then hit
the ball key or produce the sound ring
and hit the ring key we never got
the wrong sound produced before the
other key that was pretty amazing and I
I when I say never we did not have that
which was interesting so they had it
suggested they had learned associations
between the sounds and the visual forms
but then we found that they started to
produce those sounds when they were
playing with the correct object so what
Brenda and I did when we did the
analysis is we had some students just
looking at the video without the sound
because we had everything video and
audio taped and then we would just
others would rent it I would look at
just the Acoustics without the context
and when we align them so we were blind
to the context when we aligned them we
found that when we were getting the
Dolphins producing the facsimile for
computer ring it was when they were
approaching or playing with a ring
um and again here's the computer ring
here's the dolphin ring so that they
started so for example that dolphin pan
approaches the green ring and then
interacts with it they started showing
what looked to be that it could be
referential but we never claimed that
because we didn't do the requisite
studies to to check comprehension we
could look at productive use and you
know we had to be really conservative
and we wanted to be conservative and
show the patterns now this is was really
exciting for us during the study here's
the rub signal so if the dolphin pushed
the h-shaped key that helped us remember
that me human Rob
um if they push the h-shaped key they
would hear
and here's the dolphin remember we heard
franza's beautiful talk about signature
whistles pan is at the keyboard and he
puts his signature right after rub and
rolls over for a rub
we got that a few times down here you
see the W again it's a little fainer I
was changing the symbols on the keyboard
the symbol position would change every
two minutes it would freeze and then I'd
have to reposition them the computer
would say to me ball on one ring on four
would tell me where to put it and I was
changing the symbols and this is pan
rubbing on my hand where he is whistling
Rob with his signature
so this was the beginning of starting to
see these guys were actively using these
sounds back with us there's more we got
we started in the second year of the
two-year study we started getting
signals that looked like this when they
were in a particular context we think
this so this is
ring and ball and it was coming during a
period of time when they had created a
new game this is Dolphin game we called
it double toy play when they would touch
one of the symbols and get a ball and
then wait there and then touch another
one get a ring take them both and start
tossing them up into the air and that's
the context in which we heard during
this double toy play what looks to be a
combination signal now the real poetic
part of this which I really love is Jill
Tarter who I know he was invited here
today Jill was is still a friend of mine
and one of her daughter actually worked
at our at our lab Jill was sitting next
to me and it was Jill who's been looking
for signals from space looked at that
and she said that looks like ring and
ball
I love the fact that it was Jill who saw
it and it's um it's exciting because we
again we had and by the way so just to
show you this was these were the
sessions we did for the second year and
Reagan ball was not one production this
signal continued through all of these
sessions as did other signals but it was
in that one context when they were
playing with rig and bull together so it
was terribly exciting exciting for us
because now we're seeing that we gave
them these um these novel signals and
now we're seeing how they're using it
we're looking at the product the process
of vocal learning but how they may be
organizing them and just we started
seeing this evidence at least
through this data that it may be there
may be a combinatorial basis here and
that's where it gets interesting because
um we're now looking and this is we have
some unpublished data we're getting
ready to put out where we looked at some
animals
and another aquarium in a birthing
context and we now have some evidence
that they may be combining some of their
own signals into these combinatorial
signals we got this Glimpse
um a couple of years ago many years ago
I should say when I was at Marine World
where we'd see Delphi the same animals
Delphi and pan each producing their own
contact call and as they got closer
together uh the latency between the two
calls would decrease and it would become
one signal we called it a z call and
um we just didn't get enough data to
know if that was something that was
meaningful or not but I think one of the
glimpses one of the ideas I've gotten
from this is I think we should really be
looking to see if they have calls and
this could be true for sperm whales as
well if they're like subgroup calls or
affiliation calls or family calls
because that's really important to these
guys those connections those the social
relationships it may not be but I think
it's certainly worth looking at that
because we're starting to see these
things maybe they may combine calls in
some way to express relationship when we
go back and look at again these are I'm
just hypothesizing here but of course
because we don't have enough data but
when we look at this call it's when two
things were together
that we got it and um it may again these
are things that we can start testing as
a community to see you know are there
are there calls that might be
combinations and having to do spatial
spatial proximity okay so I just wanted
to share that with with all of us today
um two year they we were actually down
two years uh we did our first we had a
first year in south at Redwood City and
then we had to wait for two years to put
the keyboard in once we moved up to
Vallejo when Marine World moved I was
carrying this gets back into dolphin
memory I was carrying the keyboard out
to the pool before I even put it in they
had had no sounds in their pool for two
years and we got
oops it's not here sorry and we got a
beautiful rendition of the ball signal
from the pool so somehow the keyboard
seemed to stimulate them producing those
sounds I'm sorry again this is I I
cobbled this together at the last minute
just to say one other thing so in the
first year we had 39 sessions and we had
a split a pretty equal split uh mimicry
was just about 19 higher than productive
use so again we see a lot of this
um in young children when they're first
learning language they're mimicking and
before they use sounds in the second
year there was a significant increase in
productive use a thousand fold more
productive use than imitation they this
had gone into their repertoire and they
were using it we did not have the
werewistle to analyze all the tapes I
would love to give those tapes to
someone now to look at it when they're
using these signals in conjunction with
the other uh other whistles we'd have to
digitize everything it's still on analog
tape but carefully stored what do we
mean by immediate
imitation is where it was defined that
they produced the facsimile within a
half a sec within a second within five
seconds of the model sound
so if they hit the computer and they did
it right after that that was the window
that we used imitation everything else
was called productivity it just means
out of nothing they they make the sound
right it was either prior to hitting a
key or while they were interacting in
the session okay
um so again it raised so many questions
were the whistles are there whistles
combinatorial again uh in the terms of
their structure and organization where
the dolphin whistles facsimiles
referential
they look like they could be but we
didn't have that we didn't do the
appropriate tests we're actually testing
some of this in a new study right now at
the Roatan Institute for Marine Sciences
and again do dolphins use referential
Communication in their own repertoires
and as we heard about signature whistles
people have suggested that dolphin uh
signature whistles may be referential in
nature but again here's some of the
first evidence that they may use other
signals that are referential as well
well we were super limited by the
technology again if this was
1983 when we did this you could barely
Do It
um my colleagues and I have now created
do I have till 4 30 okay created a
dolphin touch screen we've been we've
been very fortunate to get funding from
NSF
um to do this and and do some other make
some other equipment we're using now too
we wanted to make a system that would be
dolphin safe
um so this is Marcelo magnasco and his
some of his uh post
who helped us with this Sean Woodward
and uh Jen Savoy from my lab
we worked at the National Aquarium in
Baltimore I'm going to go through this
super quickly just to give you an idea
about some of the technology that we we
can use now we built a four by eight
foot uh touch screen
um we did some programs uh we made some
games for dolphins to play the idea is
this is an optical touch screen it's not
really a touch screen at all we have a
camera behind a window and anything you
can put on your computer you can project
rear project on a touch screen and then
the Dolphins are sensed with the camera
we used polarized filters so we could
actually the cameras could see through
what we projected and um it works we
tested it with dolphins the first day we
gave the touch screen I'm going to skip
this first thing we gave the touch
screen to the Dolphins we made a wacka
whack a fish kind of game for the
Dolphins and I'm here with dolphins this
is Foster we had two two males stopped
as soon as the fish came on WE you can
see down here where they're touching
we've removed the dolphin from the
screen all the dots are the dolphin
touching immediately started touching
this these are non-technological animals
interacting like teenagers with a touch
screen
the good news is they got bored right
away after two sessions it's like that's
it not interested Sean I mean Shane I'm
sorry were they were they vocalizing uh
sometimes
not all the time but I'll show you
something else that I where they are
vocalizing we've been doing a lot of
tests we wanted to ask the question this
was for enrichment and also for learning
about their cognitive ability we gave
them project we gave them images of con
specifics bottlenose dolphins and Bob
and spotted dolphins with and without
sound we're just working up this data
now these are the two dolphins and they
showed a great deal of interest in
looking at this we did a whole study
where it's blue screen then it turns in
and then it's
15 15 seconds of blue screen or and then
this kind of screen and then blue screen
and they're actually tracking these guys
this was um and we found that they are
seem to stay whoops and then as soon as
the screen
so they're there and then Ah that's it
and we even gave them a little acoustic
signal we also looked to see whether if
we showed them a dolphin producing
bubble rings that we had recorded if
that would stimulate them to produce
bubble Rings it did not but they were
interested and they you can see their
the orientations of the Dolphins while
they're watching they're trying to track
this animal on the screen you can see
their head movements but they never
produced Bubbles and we gave them
different we showed them different
Dolphins from different facilities
producing bubbles but they were
interested
you see them following down
funny to watch this how interested they
are they and we recorded all their
vocalizations I think these can be good
tools for dolphins in in Aquaria yeah
um they've seen themselves using mirrors
we did a study with this group and
showed with these guys that they
recognized themselves younger than
children not that they're smarter
necessary they want they're on a
advanced trajectory they're born in a
really precocious State they literally
have to hit the Water swimming and their
sensory development their sense their
their sensory motor skills are are
Advanced as well so they're sort of
parallel that way but they just show it
earlier yeah
I mean so I guess my question is how
close is their eyesight to Art eyesight
and what are they you know because they
also interact with sonar and stuff like
that yeah yeah
thank you for asking it's such a great
question so you know when you watch them
you know we know that they there's some
overlapping visual Fields we've been
doing some studies on visual laterality
but these guys are right up against the
screen and it looks like there's a lot
of by by uh
not binocular um binocular vision and we
were surprised that we're not seeing
preferential Vision viewing and that how
close they're looking and we've seen
this across several studies it's true of
the mirror too because when they cut
when they came up to the mirror they
were very close to the mirror and we
were frankly really surprised by that we
would we thought that they would be much
further away and maybe show some so
show some eye bias
in our studies and as well as many other
studies they show a strong right eye
bias for foraging do you see that also
in in sperm whales oh right iPad well
they're foraging it without light so
it's a bit different but that's
something we're looking at now the final
approaches and spinning to the right
versus left yeah spinning to the right
that yeah I don't I don't I wouldn't say
there's a lateral asymmetry but it's
ongoing but yeah when dolphins are
crater feeding they always spin to the
right and go down to their eye down that
way yeah
interesting anyway
um so I don't know where this keyboard
will take us but I couldn't help putting
this one up
um the I think what's interesting is I
do think these Technologies at least for
dolphins in captivity
um that need stimulation and I I think
we can enrich their lives and that can
enrich our science as well and I do
think it's a great window uh all puns
intended into the mind of the dolphin
but I do want to mention something
because I uh real quickly so we did a I
did a paper
um we did a paper it was uh Julian Mayer
who's a French Anthropologist who's been
studying human whistled languages for
many many years Marcelo minasco my
collaborator at Rockefeller
um and the three of us have been working
together to look at human whistled
languages and the implications for
studying animal communication signals we
published this paper uh in 20 2022 it
was actually part of a conference
um and it what's so fascinating is and I
think this is such an important thing
for all of us here that
we tend to assume that animals are not I
say we in general we've assumed as a as
a species that other animals
signals are somehow just emotive that's
where we kind of came from that we're
the only
we're the only species that really pack
lots of information in these signals and
you know even with vervet monkeys it was
first assumed that vervex signals
um were emotive only and then it was
shown by uh by others that there may be
something much more semantic in those
signals so when linguists started
looking at human whistle languages and
just if those of you don't know about
human whistle languages
um renegi biznel and class and Pike I
studied with Renee when I was in
graduate school they did the first work
showing there were these human whistle
languages and these languages are all
based on tonal and atone they're they're
in both found in both tonal and a tonal
uh languages they the one thing in
common is that people who live in areas
where this where spoken word won't
travel through mountainous regions uh
distance is modify it modify their
communication so into whistles whistle
whistle language and when Renee gee and
his colleagues started looking at this
you know they thought that they could
communicate information they actually
brought them into the lab they did
x-rays look at how they produced
whistles and what was conveyed and they
say yeah we convey information
now it's now with much more work by
Julian mayor and his colleagues and he
was he he was following uh renegian and
had introduced me to Julian many years
ago they're now finding these whistles
are actually articulated there's
actually they're actually there's
actually a modification where they're
articulating vowels and consonants we
don't hear them and what's really
amazing is that legalists for years have
said these human whistle languages
cannot possibly convey information
complex information
it's the same information as in speech
because we can interrogate the whistlers
and say what's in the whistle so I think
this is a huge thing for us because
again we're so biased to thinking what
form should this should the information
be encoded in if we weren't humans and
we looked at sound spectrographs maybe
we wouldn't think that would encode
information but I think what can be in
that and when you look at things even
like if you look at whistles marcelo's
been uh has been looking at we've been
looking at fate you looking at Phase uh
phase differences in some of the and
there are so many little changes that
you don't see in a spectrogram that you
see when you look at Phase differences
the other thing I want to just mention
is that when we look at human whistle
languages because we know what words
they're representing
the individual elements are not always
separated by periods of Silence by
intervals of Silence
so in bird song and in looking at
dolphins in most animals we can Define
elements and then look at how those
elements separated by intervals of
Silence are organized
but if we looked at human speech that
way the whistled speech we'd be wrong
we're making assumptions we process
these streams of sound
psychoacoustically we have to know
something about the meaning to parse it
in a meaningful way and I think when we
look at when we look at the
communication of other animals if we can
get some kind of Cipher and you know
this is something in that you've been
looking at this idea of finding ciphers
I think by giving them some kind of
artificial code and maybe this isn't
appropriate for free-ranging Animals I I
don't know I but I think we by giving
them some kind of coding they can show
us how they use it I think it's a real
way in
to at least looking at perhaps
organization and finding a cipher yeah
foreign
okay this I think we all share you know
when we watch these animals I know so
many of us and I'm going to speak for
Roger Roger Payne who's the dear friend
of mine that we just lost you know we've
all been I think we're all really
dedicated to taking our science and
applying it in any way we can to and
raise public awareness about animals and
we can call it advocacy or we can just
call it public science communication but
I think it's terribly important because
I think our science really represents
these animals that don't have voices
that we understand to speak for
themselves so I love this meeting
because I think a lot of you share this
idea of what we can Call Scientific
advocacy and translational science and I
think it's for us scientists it really
is a time where you know we can use what
we're learning to try to get public
awareness up and get better protection
for the animals so I just always try to
get that picture anyway I'll stop
talking yeah here
um
uh okay I had a question
um like maybe and maybe this is a
technical question you were talking
about
um that these Dolphins you're working
with can translate from like a facsimile
of an object to the physical object
they can try they can produce facsimiles
of the sounds of the model sounds and
they spontaneously will use them meaning
I'm using the word spontaneous meaning
we didn't explicitly train it one could
argue that they're temporally Associated
so they're learning associations like we
do but we didn't train it explicitly by
using you know we didn't we didn't even
know when they were producing these
until we would analyze each session
later okay got it okay okay
um thank you uh my question is
um you said that that Association could
be referential but you didn't do the the
study yet so
um my question is really more about the
kind of thresholds of of meaning and so
in the social sciences right you know
I've been told by so many like you can't
say and this is going to amplify our
understanding of the Cold War because
the concept of understanding is not
measurable unlike other units of of
analysis
um so I'm really curious about the
technical processes and even the theory
behind measuring what you're calling
um I think what is understanding but
perhaps that that's the that's the
referential concept that you're that
you're trying to trying to parse yeah
yeah when we think about referential I
mean I should ask you guys what would be
convincing evidence that these were
functioning referentially
we could I mean one of the things we're
doing right now in study is we're going
to ask when they get this kind of
experience if we ask if they can
comprehend that signal
um when we give it in a new context so
if we ask an animal can you fetch if
they know to fetch something and then we
do probes where they're not trained and
we run probes and ask them we see how
else they use it I mean it's really you
know it gets into there's a thing called
Sigmund equivalency I don't know if
you're everybody's familiar with that if
I if I learn a word a spoken word and
then for for ball and then I learned the
written word or the visual word for ball
and then I see a ball there's like a b c
are they all equivalent if you learn the
connection between a and b and a and c
will you automatically do B and C and
know that they're connected there's an
equivalency between that those are the
kinds of things we want to do and
they've done a lot of that work with the
great apes so it's and and it's been
done with parrots too but it hasn't and
done with dolphins yet that's uh super
fascinating
um so it seems to me that the
referentiality is uh related to like
abstract thinking
um I'm wondering or like um
transductional translational thinking so
have you done experiments where like you
have two different kinds of rings and
then the the the icon of the ring or not
the I sorry the icon of the ball that is
not produced in like a circle shape that
that's generalizable knowledge they can
understand like the object the
functionality of what a ring is at
different scales we've got yeah well we
we haven't done an explicit experiment
what we do is we give them lots of
different kinds of balls lots of
different kinds of rings and we get that
sound no matter what that uh if it's
within that category of object if that's
that's the closest you've gotten yeah
right
foreign
and I'm wondering to what extent do you
or anyone you know do stuff like
herbs or other part you know like swim
faster yeah something relevant to them
yeah right yeah
um trainers have used signals to get
animals to do a fast swim better than a
slow swim in a trained context Lou
Herman's lab
has done lots of work teaching gestural
communication to dolphins it was they
did it in Step way a stepwise way where
they use food and social rewards but it
was reinforced by food but there was a
lot of social praise which is important
and they trained them on nouns and verbs
but then modifiers okay so it could be
an object that was to the left or the
right and they could they worked with
two different Dolphins okay Mayan
Phoenix and did inverse grammars with
them too so they're showing that the
Dolphins could learn independent of the
specific grammar that each dolphin had a
different grammar that they used that
makes sense they did a lot of really
fascinating work a lot so if anybody's
interested in that
go ahead I've asked a few questions
already okay no no please
is there any research on dolphins
expressing emotions so this this sound
for pain this other song for excitement
I've been sitting on this paper for a
long time and there has been work and I
think it's critical okay
um years ago John Lilly we were talking
about Lily who who did a lot of early
work it made it a lot of his work was
highly speculative it made it very
difficult for a lot of us afterwards
because he speculated about things and
raised I think a public
um anticipation but some of the work a
lot of the work he did earlier and that
was published in science
um he reported a distress call
and he said and this call looked like a
rise and then a falling call and
sometimes it had a break in it and we
have a good deal of data on this and I
think that
um it's quite interesting because if we
could find a call that represented
distress uh that would be a great
predict that would help us in terms of a
welfare you know Animal Welfare
um
this is uh we we I've presented this or
some things already I think often what
we do but what happens is we've seen
this call in a variety of contexts in
different facilities it's there's this
call has been Associated
um with uh periods of time when an
animal will die over a weekend and if
you look at their normal uh signature
whistle it's different when than what
this distress call is we actually have
some data that we're working up now it
personally I think what we've got is a
signature whistle and then a falling
component that may be distress
um there's a 1966 paper about this by
biznel and his colleagues as well about
the stress calls I think this is a
really important area for work because
in terms of this is lawyer and me in
terms of translational science advocacy
this is what you need I mean the in
terms of Animal Welfare the first thing
that anyone who's been
non-expert in Dolphins would understand
is that there's there might be something
going on in terms of producing distress
address to dolphins that could be
equivalent to torture and something
along those in the Cove many of you know
the film The Cove I I was I was the
person who told Louis sohoy as the
Director about this I was doing advocacy
work to try to stop that in Japan I
won't prolong this but we have I got
recordings of the Dolphins in these
Drive hunts and they're these falling
calls frequently when it starts
um no I think I think you're absolutely
right I mean I think if we can when we
can start really translating what
animals are doing in um and that's and
there are many species that show
distress Halls by the way
um that we know that are published I
think one of the really interesting
things beyond that is that in looking to
see if there's any University out
universality of what we see in distress
calls because there are many species
that will have a falling slope in a
distressed call as well so that's
is there any expression
behaviorally yes you do see this and
I've seen this it's been well reported
uh have you seen this in in any of the
whales that you've observed when one
animal that's particularly close with
another dies you'll see anything unusual
you don't have anything like the calf
carrying like
I mean these were like viral videos
recently too that we've never seen that
in the sperm whales we've seen the
opposite which is like a clear
joy of the of new calves when they're
very new but we haven't seen anything
but I suppose that's the difference
between happy birthday and a funeral
right right one is more acoustic than
the other uh at least in humans so I'm
it's that it's a fascinating space for
sure and in elephants there's that
there's evidence of changes in Behavior
around yeah yeah and then and also in
Dolphins you'll see uh we'll often see
we saw this at Marine World where I was
working in in the area where they were
doing more demonstrations where the
closest uh budding of one of the animals
has died Spock completely went off her
feet the other animals didn't and I've
heard this reported before yeah
what's going on inside and um
I just had I just had one question at
this time
um one of the things that is most
fascinating to me is the the results you
described where they appear to combine
their signature whistle with something
else and it makes me wonder if there's a
possibility that they're using their own
signature whistle referentially to refer
to themselves just as it's been
suggested that they use imitations of
signature whistles to referentially
refer to somebody else almost the same
way that we use the pronoun I to refer
to ourself is it pot do you think it's
possible that they're using like when
they're stringing together their
signature whistle with a stress call or
stringing together the artificial
symbol for a belly rub with themselves
that they're indicating that this
applies to me
I I don't know it's I think it's
provocative finding that we saw I think
actually we're doing some work on that
now in a new study so maybe we'll have
more of the report because it's we don't
really know the nature of how they
perceive their own signal do we and we
know that they can refer to others
um but we don't know about their own
perception so something we're looking at
right now at this new project we're
working on
um so it's an interesting thing I don't
know I'm not you're doing the elephant
work is it are you the person yeah I'm
dying to hear about this it sounds
fascinating thanks we have so much to
learn it's such a great time for us to
be working together now in these schools
questions any more questions
yeah I was wondering I was interested in
what you said about like the uh like
creation of the segmentation problem and
like the yeah because in
uh like in language acquisition from
from what I know like there it's kind of
a puzzle because the way you know how to
say about words is because you know what
the words mean and so you can tell them
apart right because we don't actually
stop there's apart from like maybe meter
uh cues there there's no like signal as
to like when a work starts when another
one begins I was wondering like you say
this is no good problem in the beginning
but what you think about like how to
figure out like a set of vocabulary
items or like how to start doing
segmentation at all yeah I get I think
it gets into trying to figure out what
the smallest units are to see how it
breaks down that's why I think this even
whistle language work I mean this is a
great database if anybody wants to work
on this I think it's superb and we've
been dying to find the right group to
work with to look at these human
whistles and it would be great to it
would be great to test this how how good
are we at defying finding this with
human resource if we can look at the
smallest elements because we know what
they are seeing how they're combined
doesn't mean other animal communication
systems are all at all organized like
this at all but it'll be a great test
bank I think to try it and then see you
know to sharpen our skills
pretty much doesn't have
segments okay and see that's the thing
we always go I think one what's so
interesting is that for us because we
don't know how it's how it's divided up
we sort of have historically said okay
if their silences we'll Define this as
an element and the other and we're kind
of we just don't we have no way to test
that yet so that's why I thought these
even whistle language things at least
gets us thinking about that and also I
think again the fact that you can put
complex information in a simple list
looking signal whether it's clicks
organized a certain way or whistles you
know we we just these are big brains
all right thank you thank you very much
[Applause]
so so face yourself
I'll just also close up for the live
stream
um for the people that I was sitting on
the live stream that will start up again
tomorrow at 9 30 in the morning